[Music]
there were two
warriors i kill for a spicy tuna roll
right about now
get yourself a little something the
brothers grew apart and a new age began
in the middle edge dad uncle 10 coming
for christmas this year sweetie
sometimes you just
grow apart
you can't solve everything with money
but you can you haven't changed at all
you're still a big baby
suck it ted you suck out of my face
excuse me
i hate to interrupt i mean it's a
riveting conversation but why don't you
suck it
she can talk a lot
i'm in the family business and now you
work for me boomers
baby corp developed a new formula that
can turn a grown-up back into a baby for
48 hours
you want me to be a baby again
[Music]
yep there's the awkward stage ew
baby corp will offer a full memory wipe
following this experience
so what's the crisis an evil genius is
teaching
kids to be very bad bad babies
welcome to the baby evolution we're
gonna need a disguise to go undercover
what have you done to me yeah no really
going sailing
oh no
[Music]
thanks for always having my back you're
my brother we always stick together
because that's what families do
we need to hurry before the formula
wears off
what the [ __ ] aren't you a cutie in that
little karate outfit
oh my gosh oh my gosh oh my gosh i'm
sure this isn't something money
can't solve what the fudge
[Music]
bye